every star in the sky probably has
planets Y and life is probably emerging
on these planets but this the amount of
contingency that is associated with life
is that I think the commentarial space
Associated to these planets is so
different we are never going to our
causal cones are never going to overlap
or not easily and this is a thing that
makes me sad about alien life why it's
why we have to create alien life in the
lab as quickly as possible because I
don't know if we are going to be able to
be able to build um architectures that
will intersect with alien Co
intelligence C and architectures
intersect you you know I mean in time or
space time and the ability to
communicate the ability to communicate
yeah my biggest fear in a way is that
life is everywhere but we become
infinitely more lonely because of our
Scaffolding in that commentarial space
because it's so big and so so you're
saying the the constraints created by
the environment that led to the factory
of darwinian
evolution are just like this a little
tiny cone in a nearly Infinite
combinatorial Space so there's other
cones like it and and what why can't we
communicate with other like just because
we can't create it doesn't mean we can't
appreciate the creation right like that
sorry detect the creation I I I truly
don't know but I it's an excuse for me
to ask for people to give me money to
make a planet simulator yeah right if I
can make with a different different like
another Shameless say it's like give me
money I need money this was all long
plug for a planet simulator it's like
you know hey I will be the first in line
to my my my uh my Rick my Rick garage
has run out of room you know yeah no um
and this is a planet simulator you mean
like a different kind of planet or
different sets of environments and
pressures exactly if we could basically
recreate the selection before biology as
we know it that gives rise to a
different biology we should be a to put
the constraints on where I look in the
universe so here's a thing here's my
here's my dream yeah my dream is that by
creating life in the lab based upon
constraints we understand like let's
like go for Venus type life or earth
type life or something again do earth
2.0 screw it let's do earth 2.0 an earth
2.0 has a different genetic alphabet
fine that's fine different um protein
alphabet fine have cells and evolution
all that stuff we will then be able to
say okay life is a more General
phenomena selection is more General than
than what we think is Con the chemical
constraints on life and we can point the
James web and other telescopes at other
planets that we are in that zone we are
most likely to con combinatorially
overlap with
right so because you know we B so there
chemistry looking for some overlap and
then we can then basically um shine
light on them literally and white look
at light coming back and apply Advanced
assembly Theory to Lang general theory
of language that we will get and say
hauh we in that signal it looks random
but there's a copy number
oh this random set of things that
shouldn't be that looks like a a true
random number generator has
structure as a not com not kagol off AIT
type structure but evolutionary
structure given by assembly Theory and
we start to um but I would say that cuz
I'm a Shameless assembly theorist yeah I
it just feels like the the cone I might
be misusing the word cone here but the
width of the cone is growing
faster um is grow really fast to where
eventually all the cones
overlap even in a very very very large
commentator
space I I it
just but then again if you're saying the
universe is uh also growing very quickly
in terms of possibilities that's re I
hope that as we
build as we build
abstractions the main I mean one one
idea is that as we go to
intelligence intelligence allows us to
look at the regularities around us in
the
universe and that gives us some common
grounding to to discuss with aliens and
and you might be right that that there
we will overlap there even though we
have completely different chemistry
literally completely different chemistry
um um that we will be a to pass
information from one another but it's
not a given and um you know I have to
kind of try and divorce hope and emotion
you know away from what I under I can
logically justify but it's just hard to
Intuit it a world a universe where
there's nearly infinite complexity
objects and they somehow can't detect
each other but the universe is expanding
but the nice thing is I would say I
would look you see I think Carl Sean did
the wrong well not the wrong thing he he
flicked the Voyager PRO brand pale blue
dot said look how big universe is I
would have done it the other way around
said look at the voyage of pro that came
from the planet Earth that came from
Luca look at how big Earth is
MHM then it produced that It produced
that yeah and that I think is like
completely
amazing